We're coming to you from a place
that is definitely
Rio de Janeiro,
and not a studio across
from a 7/11 in Los Angeles.
(laughter)
...for...
-(applause and cheering)
-It's not.
-This is Rio.
-Yeah.
It's definitely Rio.
I promise this is Rio.
I was robbed four times
on the way to the lectern.
-(laughter) -This is a weeklong
@midnight tournament
that'll be just
like the Olympics.
And by that I mean underfunded
and on an annoying tape-delay.
(laughter)
We've scoured the globe
for the funniest people
from the funniest countries,
-and also Germany, and brought
them here... -(laughter)
...to test their wits,
their humor,
and their ability to share
one functioning toilet.
And now, I would like
to welcome you all
to the @midnight Olympics!
-(cheers and applause)
-(fanfare plays)
-Hey, stop. stop.
-(music stops)
Unfortunately,
I can't do that because
the International Olympic
Committee sent out a letter
threatening legal action
against non-sponsors who...
"read tweets about the games
"and any
of its associated trademarks.
"That includes
the words 'Olympics,'
'Olympian,' and '#TeamUSA.'"
I can't even congratulate
Olympic athletes
on their victories, only
for non-Olympic things. Like...
Like, for instance,
if I saw this picture
of a celebrating Michael Phelps,
all I could say is,
"Congratulations
on your perfect nipples."
(applause and cheering)
They're perfect
in every single way.
But despite
all these legal barriers,
we're still going
to kick off our tribute
to that ancient tradition
of greased-up,
uncircumcised wrestlers
with an awesome
torch-lighting ceremony.
Let the game-like
activities start! Comed...
-(orchestra plays
grand theme) -Oh.
Is it happening?
I feel it.
(cheers and applause)
Comedians, what other things
do we have to do
to avoid getting sued
by the I.O.C.?
-Yakov Smirnoff, go.
-The Olympics game--
you are not supposed to do drugs
or take drugs.
On this show,
it's mandatory to take...
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Yeah.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
Hopefully, everyone's
juiced up and ready to go.
Flula Borg.
You cannot swallow
any raw sewage
without a
raw sewage-swallowing permit.
And good luck getting that
all because
of bureaucracy red tape!
-All right, points. Yes, very
good. Very good. -(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Thank you.
Maeve Higgins.
You cannot, um, hire
the IOC as your secretary
and then sexually harass them.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
No, you can't do that.